étranger
je ne peux pas aller en Érythrée parce que j'ai un
problème j'ai un gros problème avec le
gouvernement et je ne peux pas quand Dieu l'Érythrée
je ne sais pas ce qui m'est arrivé
maintenant je suis fatigué je n'ai pas le pouvoir d'
aller dans un autre pays et le  nouveau
pays dans la nouvelle vie je pense que c'est une
fin pour moi ce n'est pas le cas je n'ai pas de
pouvoir plus de pouvoir pour faire quoi que ce soit
d'étranger
je ne peux pas dormir la nuit parce que
j'ai beaucoup de problèmes dans ma vie avant
et maintenant
vient un nouveau  problème qu'est-ce que le Rwanda, sauf
non, je n'ai aucune idée,
Monsieur le Président,
que la réinstallation des demandeurs d'asile
au Rwanda est cohérente Traverser
d'autres pays sûrs et qu'ils ne devraient pas
choisir de venir au Royaume-Uni